hello everyone and welcome to the
craziest game of day one of the world
rapid blitz championship that's
currently being played in poland uh and
uh well a lot of you guys have requested
this one basically this is the most
requested game from uh from the first
day young shish of duda versus badr
jobaba and both of them are on four
points going into round five and whoever
wins this uh will be the sole leader
after uh the first day as they will have
five out of five so without further ado
let's check it out it's quite a crazy
one the engine bar was playing ping pong
with itself for for most of the game uh
so let's uh enjoy it uh duda with the
white pieces opens with d4 we have d5c4
and uh jubava says that he does not
respect his opponent at all he plays the
captures on c4 except the queen's gambit
and this is one of the gambits that
people usually don't accept but he is
showing that he is ready to fight and
that he wants to play for the win with
the black pieces
so knight to f3 uh we have knight to f6
and e3 now preparing to pick up the pawn
here bishop to g4 and now bishop
captures on c4 uh the so-called yanovsky
larson variation we have e6 h3
challenging the bishop bishop to h5 and
knights to c3 and again the knight is
usually developed to d7 so you can
advance the c pawn but jebaba doesn't
care he just wants to be
i will as close to the action with his
pieces so knight to c6 we have a3 a6 and
now there are some games where b4 was
played also bishop back to e2 was uh uh
was played so you can move your knight
uh castles is a known move but here duda
plays g4 and it is now as of move 9 that
we have a completely new game so bishop
back to g6 we have knight h4 going after
the bishop and the bishop to d6 now just
continuing development knight capture
spawn captures and bishop to d2 now so
uh white eliminated one of black's
bishops but black has the open h file to
use uh to be used for for the rook so e5
uh jobover tries to open up the center
the white king also still an a1
and d5 duda keeping the center close
knight to e7 and now even g5 kicking the
other knight back as well knights to d7
and now queen to g4 uh we have knights
to f5 and now uh this knight is
excellently placed and for the moment
you can't really kick it away any e4
ideas can be met with either rook to h4
or you can even go knights to d4 you
don't want to free this square for the
knight so instead h4 uh taking away the
square from the black rook and now
bishop back to e7
uh we have queen side castles by duda
and now knight to d6 attacking the
bishop which are back to e2 and denied
knight to c5 so a really crazy position
where white definitely controls a lot of
space but it's a raptor game
it's hard to you know make sense of of
what's what so queen back to g2
preparing bishop to g4 at some point
because black has to develop the queen
somehow and probably queen to d7 will be
played so b5 jubav already starting the
attack on the queen side and he's
probably going to castle king's side
even though this h pawn is already very
far advanced but uh it is going to be an
extremely double-edged double-edged
position so king to c2 doesn't want to
see this knife coming to b3 and rook to
b8 now preparing to further push with b4
and now knight to a2 controlling that b
for square even though b4 here is
perfectly fine and is the strongest move
for white uh as it is in many positions
so here at knights to a2 controlling b4
and now queen to d7 and now that the
queen has been developed the bishop is
coming to g4 so bishop g4 attacks the
queen and now knight to f5 uh we have
knight to b for now uh trying to get the
knight all the way to c6 and rook to b6
it's going to be very useful here at
least when the knight comes to c6 your
rook will not be attacked so bishop to
c3 attacking the e5 pawn and now juba
starts the attack on the queen side with
a3 a5 attacking the knight on b4 knight
to c6 and now finally b4 and uh well
that's what you get when you don't push
b4 with the white pieces so bishop
captures an e5 we have b captures on a3
b captures an a3 and now your bava just
castle saying your king is wide open i'm
gonna attack on the queen side and even
though the engine prefers white uh in
this position and you can very easily
open up the
the game with h5 it's very very hard to
play this with little time on the clock
so do that starts with h5 this is the
absolute best way to continue the game
and uh jubava uh takes the knight on c6
plays rook captures on c6 and now he
wants to get to the queen inter game via
queen to e6 and the queen to b3 so the
captures and the queen of e6 going for
that queen to b3 check then it could be
a little bit dangerous so of course duda
blocks this he plays queen to d5 and now
knight captures an e3 with a nice
forking check but also you're going to
pick up the bishop with the queen so f
captures on e3 queen captures on g4 and
it seems like jobava made a little bit
of progress here but the position is
completely winning for white so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the winning idea for duda while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the idea
that you have to open up this diagonal
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the move is h6 this is
completely crushing and there is no way
for black to defend this position i'm
just going to show you a really fun line
to give you an example of what happens
uh well if if
black puts up a decent amount of defense
let's say queen f5 check you're going to
block this with e4 let's say knight
captures an e4 now black is threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries why to
just place h captures on g7 and there's
really nothing
you can do here for example knight f6
check you open up a discovery here and
you can even win the white queen
but white doesn't care just rook d3 and
now if you capture the the queen with
knight captures the rook h8 is checkmate
so you can't allow this uh the you can't
allow the bishop to defend the g7 pawn
and if you play some like king captures
on g7 then we move the bishop and that's
it there is no move you can play here uh
for example queen captures and d5 is met
with rook captures on d5 and that's it
uh we're just gonna gobble up all of the
pieces here and white is up simply too
much material and instead of maybe
trading queens you could go for queen
captures and g5 but it doesn't help
we're we're just going to capture the
queen here so
that's actually a silly move but uh
there are no moves you can play here
it's just a completely hopeless position
so instead after queen captures on g4 uh
dude that doesn't go h6 he goes h
captures and g6 which also looks very
appealing you open up the h file but you
don't quite open up this diagonal so
here we have queen to f5 with check e4
and now queen captures on g6 this is the
pawn that of course jobava grabs and
he's gonna capture on e4 next so bishop
to f6 uh here you there are a lot of
moves you can play and there are a lot
of good moves for example rook to h4
followed by rook to h1 you could deliver
rook to h8 checkmate but it's it's uh as
if jubala's madness was transferred over
to duda and he started playing mad moves
so bishop to f6 he now wants of course
black to capture so he can put a rook on
g1 uh but joba just ignores him bishop
to d6 we have bishop back to d4 uh now
attacking the knight here but knight
captures on e4 now threatening all sorts
of nasty discoveries rook sorry not king
c1 rook to d3 now blocking the nasty
discoveries and now rook to e8
we have king to b3 getting the king out
of harm's way and now knight captures
and g5 so you can see that jobaba
cleared all the problems he had in front
of his king both of the pawns have been
eliminated and how do you play this uh
it's a pretty equal-ish position but
still with the white king is wide open
the black king is very safe behind his
pawn so it's not easy to play this with
white bishop back to c3 we have rooked a
b8 check king the a2 and now we have
knight to e4 uh attacking the bishop
here so king to a1 not allowing this
capture to come with check but this is
actually even worse
uh we have knight captures on c3 you
could even go for this fork knight to f2
uh but jobava goes for the absolute best
knight captures in c3 rook captures and
queen to f6 now attacking the rook here
the rook cannot move and next you're
gonna play bishop to e5 add another
attacker to the rook you're gonna play
rook b3 add another attacker to the rook
and there's nothing white can do here
unless
uh so here queen to d3 defending the
rook now rook to b3 how will you defend
this uh well queen to h7 check king to
f8 queen to h8 to check king is seven
and now rook the e1 check uh luckily uh
he has bishop to e5 otherwise it would
be checkmate the king has no squares so
here we have bishop to e5 and now queen
to c8 uh going for this queen to d7
check and here we have queen to e6 and
this is a terrible mistake in such a
tricky situation you have to play queen
to d6 although it looks a little bit
weird because your pawn is already
defending this pawn but not really the
bishop is pinned so here queen to e6 was
played just to give you an example if
queen to d6 we're going to go into this
first line queen d7 check and once this
is traded at first we captured the
bishop with check and once the king
moves this is the only good move for
black we're going to capture here rook
captures on c3 rook captures and a5 king
captures on d7 and we have this rook and
upon end game where black is up two
pawns and of course completely winning
so this is what uh uh joba has to go for
however he played queen to e6 and now he
simply allows duda queen captures on c7
check that's very unfortunate for him uh
bishop captures on c7 rook captures on
e6 with king captures and the rook
captures on b3 uh we have king to d5 now
uh juba is still up upon but it's a rook
against the bishop we have rook to c3
defending the pawn now f5 now jubala
will start pushing his past pawns king
b1 of course we have g5 king the c2 we
have g4 king to d3 now f4 they are
closing off the king from uh
attacking those pawns so here we have a4
uh and f3 now we have king to e3 and now
king to e5 so hopefully one of those
pawns can be promoted but it's not going
to be easy with the king and rook uh so
rook to c5 check king the d6 attacking
the rook rook back to c4
bishop to b6 check king to f4 and now
even f2 threatening f1 queen so rook to
c1 defending and now king to c7 uh we
have king captures on g4 and now bishop
to e3 attacking the rook and now the
rook cannot keep an eye on the f1 square
and also on the c6 spawn so rook to h1
and now we play king captures on c6 and
now if we can capture this pawn as well
then it will be very good for us but
white will try of course to prevent this
king f3 we have bishop to c5 and now
king to e4 we have bishop to b4 trying
to put the bishop on e1 so the bishop
defends both of the pawns and you no
longer have to worry about anything king
d4 we have bishop to e1 and now rook to
h6 with check and now the king cannot uh
reach uh the a4 pawn so you have to go
back king d7 now rook f6
and that there is no way for either side
to make progress uh rook to f5 we have
king to e7 uh rook to f5 now getting out
of harm's way king e6 rook to f3 king d6
rooked f6 check king to a7 rook to f3
and he was in this position uh on move
70 that the players agreed to a draw
which means that neither player will
finish the first day on five out of five
rather both of them are now on four and
a half out of five same as magnus
carlsen uh who only uh drew one game and
won the other four so after they won uh
duda joba and magnus are leading the
tournament we're gonna see what happens
in day two and if more crazy games like
this will will be happening uh so yeah
uh that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh thank you for
suggesting it i would like to thank
czech made epilepsy catherine matriarch
jack schroeder jeffrey redinor and david
kimura for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of day two as it
starts very soon
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day